hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video eine lieblingsbeschäftigung ist es
für komische betreute videos auf
facebook anzugucken
jetzt gerade mit kartoffeln und gekocht
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
lass euch heute mal daran teilhaben hat
sich letztes beispielsweise auf facebook
ein video laptop ohne katze auf einem
rund gekostet hat habe ich mir gedacht
luca es gibt so viele skurrile sache mit
der durch ich sehe so freundlich täglich
irgendwelche sachen wo ich freunde
darunter markiere oder selber markiert
beide sachen die ich liebe dich einfach
cool witzig bescheuert finde warum
machst du nicht einfach mal ein video
bei vier von solchen videos
das tue ich heute im ersten video was
wir heute zeigen geht es um diese
personen hier gehen kann man jetzt sogar
nicht richtig erkennen das ist nämlich
irgendein typ in der arena eben im
fußballstadion und man sieht auch schon
dass hier und hier ordner stehen und die
sind beide so ein bisschen den alarm
stellung naja der und schilder nicht nur
seine baseball guckt so jedenfalls ist
dieser typ in dem schwarzen t shirt kein
ganz normaler typ der da sein soll
sondern ein flitzer und was machen
flitzer ein flitzer bezeichnet man
menschen die auf öffentlichen
veranstaltungen oder plätzen durch das
geschehen laufen um die aufmerksamkeit
auf sich zu ziehen wobei sie häufig ganz
oder teilweise unbekleidet sind also mal
schauen ob er das schafft die
aufmerksamkeit auf sich zu ziehen
ok betrieb hat jetzt wirklich schon so
zwei drei ordner ausgeschaltet durch
seine zickzack bewegung machen wir
schauen mal ob es weiter schafft
und zu diesem zeitpunkt hatte der
flitzer weg ich nur noch zwei leute vor
sich ich war normale menschen würden
jetzt denken diese ordner und beamten
dort im stadion werden dafür bezahlt
dass sie vielleicht wenn mal ein blitzer
alle 50 spieler aufs spielfeld laufen
will dass sie ihn davon abhalten auf
spielfeld zu laufen
die müssten das ja eigentlich verhindern
können vor allem weil erhalten gelockert
20 ordner waren und ein komischer plätze
aber wir schauen mal weiter
ja der flitzer hat es wirklich geschafft
an 20 ordnern vorbei zu laufen und bis
aufs fußballfeld zu kommen also von mir
auf jeden fall eine menge respekt ich
habe euch übrigens auch normales leben
davon vorbereitet
man kann sagen was man will und mich
selber spitze auf ich weiß
beispielsweise als dieser youtuber mit
alice dass bei einem wm spiel gemacht
hat mich dass auch mega abgebaut aber
ich zolle den typen höchsten respekt
dafür dass er es geschafft hat zwischen
locker 20 ordnern und beamten wo dies
ein beamter irgendwie durch zu laufen
und das zu schaffen aufs spielfeld zu
kommen natürlich strafbar und blöde das
stört oder spiegelt aber ich meinen
bambus oder soll irgendwo wir lachen
können bei einem nächsten video was ich
heute zeigen möchte geht es um diesen
rugby beziehungsweise footballspieler
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was
sie da gerade spielen aber wenn ihr
american sportexperte sein können wir
sehr gerne in die kommentare schreiben
wie ich erst hey das ist eine etwas
korpulentere junge der irgendwie
football rugby spiel war aber in amerika
und gegend wieder halt den ball gerade
hat aber wir schauen uns den clip mal
ran
der junge ist schon irgendwie sehr gut
man fragt sich jetzt natürlich erst mal
nach dem clip ok keiner traut sich den
irgendwie so richtig anzugreifen haider
geht er jetzt richtig kasse den
zweikampf rein ich zeige euch mal woran
das liegen könnte
dieser junge ist neun und rente da ich
irgendwelche anderen neunjährigen auf
dem footballfeld um jedenfalls dass der
sudan hingefallen und anstatt sich
normal aufzurappeln und zu sagen okay
ich liebe es den ball ab oder ich weiß
nicht genau wie das funktioniert beim
pumpen oder rugby was aber das ist man
dann stellt er sich dort aufhielten
macht er
er regelt das nächste kind um und macht
danach natürlich den kommerz jetzt
denken auch vielleicht weil das kind in
dem moment ihnen die aggressiv drauf und
dass man nur in dem spiel zu geben wie
jetzt so ein typisches beispiel ich habe
euch hier nochmal einen anderen spiel zu
vorbereitet der kleine junge hat er
wirklich irgendwie drei kinder innerhalb
von drei vier sekunden einfach alle
umgedacht und dann immer noch nicht alle
wert das ist einfach ultra kran und ich
meine es wenn ich der coolste rugby
spieler die ich je gesehen habe bin ich
danach auch noch den punkt machen würde
hier nochmal eine einwendung wo er
ebenfalls aggressiv spielt allerdings in
einem komplett anderen spielen und leute
es ist wichtig so kein nach der
gegenspieler hat gegen sie bock den
typen anzugreifen weil sie glaube ich
glaube ich wirklich einfach angst davor
haben dass er die box und den irgendwas
brechen könnte um euch das mal zu
demonstrieren habe ich hier auch auf den
kleinen tv bereitet er zeigt dass er
wichtig ein spieler neben ihm herab der
locker irgendwie schneller alles als er
aber sich einfach nicht traut ihn
anzugreifen
ich würde es einfach richtig fasziniert
wie krass das ist das einfach keine sich
traut ihn anzugreifen
ein kleiner rat von mir die trainer okay
ihr sprecht englisch und versteht mich
wahrscheinlich gerade nicht ich verstehe
nicht wieso sie den jungen in der u9 las
nur die nicht in die u11 stecken wo er
beispielsweise mit älteren leuten
zusammen später kann ich doch viel
besser weiter entwickelt seine hände und
einer leuten rum ketsch verstehen was
ich meine
in diesem clip sitzt halt ein mann mit
seiner frau im auto irgendwo in amerika
dem bahnübergang und der mann redet was
von wegen jahr da ist und danach sagt
der mann auch noch die ganze zeit
irgendwie sowas wie tablet also von
wegen es auch zu seiner frau und er sagt
noch öfter tablet und dann passierte das
was die frau aufnehmen sollte
ein fucking zug rast in einen lkw und
essig ich habe es ihr euch die ganze
zeit hier auf replay laufen ich finde es
einfach nur mega kratz also dieser
dieser lkw ist wohl irgendwie bei den
bahnübergang gefahren als die
frankfurter gegangen sind und und
eingeklemmt zwischen den ich weiß nicht
genau was wie das passiert ist ja bald
nur dieses video hier gesehen und mich
nicht weiter darüber informiert muss ich
ehrlich gesagt zu geben
ich denke mal nicht dass dabei jemand
ums leben gekommen ist oder schwer
verletzt wurde weil es jetzt nicht so
kranke aus da also es ist jetzt nicht so
als als mächtig zugesetzt nicht eine
wand gefahren
der zug hat sich danach ausgeräumt sind
ist ja auch nicht enteist oder so kann
ich einfach nur mega kratz als ich
dieses video entdeckt habe also ich
glaube jeder mensch ist findet einfach
solche sachen kräftig wenn irgendwas
krasses ineinander flieg crash keine
ahnung war es deswegen hoffe ich
wirklich einfach nur dass dabei nichts
passiert ist aber ich wollte ja dieses
video zeigen weil es gerade auch schon
um die welt geht kommen wir nun zu den
video weswegen ihr wahrscheinlich hier
zeit weil es im titel also geschrieben
steht
ich war mal wieder letzte vor facebook
unterwegs und hab dann gesehen dass die
bilden video geteilt hat für das von ihr
angeguckt hat gesehen dass der guardian
das video geteilt und dann noch neigen
und viele andere website dann hab ich
mir gedacht okay ich guck mir das jetzt
mal an
ok stock satz da gerade ein mann auf
seinem fahrrad mit 27
was ist das für ein mensch regie haben
wir davon noch einen anderen tipp parat
korrekt jammern ich mein ok in
deutschland ist es so wenn ziegen oder
tiere von a nach b gebracht werden da
gibt es da für lkws bewegen welche
anderen fortbewegungsmittel oder
irgendwie dass die leute daher gehen wir
von einem fenster laufen er macht sein
mal auf seinem fahrrad kann man mal
machen
das hat ihr von dem video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wenn es das getan hat freue ich
mich über eine bewertung von euch hier
seht ihr ein smiley eingeblendet wenn
ihr darauf könnt ihr meinen kanal
abonnieren wer auf jeden fall wollte
natürlich werde jetzt machen würden und
hier findet ihr ein anderes video
eingeblendet was verlinkt ich an da
irgendein rennen video könnt ihr mal
drauf kriegen wir auf jeden fall auch
chillig ich heiße laserdrucker auf
instant search and musical sucht
reisebeschreibungen und hecken an meinem
job abschied habe schreiber und dann
sehen wir uns im nächsten video